Catherine which economic threat is most
likely to trigger the next recession
Trump right now normally I would say
presidents get too much credit when the
economy is good too much blame when the
economy is bad I've been saying that for
months when people ask me about Trump
versus Obama in the economy or whatever
else but Trump is making so many
unforced errors at this point everything
from the trade wars plural to the
government shutdown to threatening the
Independence of the Federal Reserve I'm
amazed it's a lasted this long
economy I mean in a sense it's
surprising statistically because this is
now the second longest recovery on
record in history in all of history so
it's like a little long in the tooth no
matter what it's surprising that it's
still stuck around given all of the
policy errors that Trump has made so
that's what I'm worried we don't have a
lot of money to bail banks out like we
did last time or beyond well partly
because we just spent two trillion
dollars on a tax cut Cyrus is your law
with your name on it still working or
debate debate in good shape yes they
didn't they weren't able to what they've
got to do in particular with the
consumer Bureau is to not administer it
but they didn't even dare try to change
it and it's still mostly in good shape
and it has stopped the best approach and
he's absolutely right that and I think
that's the biggest economic problem we
got this artificial rush from the tax
cut and that's petering out and by the
way that's where that's what I'm an
infrastructure we spent the
infrastructure money on the tax cut
that's why there would be no significant
infrastructure improvement which could
give the atrani the right kind of boost
because it all went for the textbook ok
Marshawn Lynch did you try and light a
blunt off al Davis's eternal flame at
the last Raiders game in Oakland I think
you did Abby you did
I think I think there's only right to
saying you know I think it was only
right to send the Raiders off and write
real Oakland in a real Oakland way and
were you were there with their
repercussions from the NFL for that I
mean I don't think they caught on yet
but I mean I'm pretty sure now at this
point yeah
something will take place they got you
for skittles on your sneaker light up
lunch off of a guy's eternal flame
that's not a very bright league is it
yeah that's foul Davis right okay Barney
do you hope Democrats will push for oh
no I guess I asked you that do you think
Alexandre Acacio Cortez is a good fit
for the House Financial Services
Committee he's doing great so far boy
what a star well I have a problem with
some of this having people that were sit
in and then she pokes his office was
really stupid
here's the deal I think it's important I
worry about people on the left picking
an easy fight with their friends on the
new left as opposed to find the real
enemy that's what I was just saying and
you were yelling at me no you were
talking about signaling
I agree people should get a second I
think ripples have been inconsistent
saying no second chance for sexual
harassment but yes for robbery I think
so I agree with that but I do think she
has a problem in misidentifying the she
thinks the reason we're not doing better
is that some of the liberals haven't
been fighting hard enough the problem is
the year the opposition of the
Republican so I hope she has she puts
all that energy into fighting the right
enemy Erik Erikson should Steve King's
comments be viewed as an isolated
incident or are they a symptom of racism
dominating the Republican Party I think
they're a Steve King problem but I think
there's a real problem with Republicans
who weren't willing to speak up quickly
about them you know I've known Steve
King and I've kind of been shocked at
this evolution of him I don't know him
well but he's
very blatantly about things I didn't
even know he believed its examine rates
I find Pete
it really is there's a symptomatic of
this presidential administration making
people feel comfortable being [ __ ]
when they didn't necessarily yes for
years if not decades I mean that is as
big as cantaloupe comments I have never
heard the and you're right the New York
Times ran a long time line of comments
he had made I never even heard it but
this look that got worse to see people
defending him to say no that's not
really what he meant it was what he
meant
yeah and I do think they're Republicans
you got Tim Scott calling out the
Republicans and I think it's right if
the Republicans can't clean their own
house the voters totally will and at
some point they're gonna stop worrying
about cleaning the Republicans house
they're just gonna pour kerosene around
the outside of the party and strike a
match yeah I mean I've seen so many
people though who used to be what I
would call normal Republicans who then
Thurman Devin Nunez had some pretty
smart quotes I swear to God I read them
on this show years ago he became this
person it happens a lot
I think it's Fox News I think they get
sucked into the Fox V your title pages
III think that it has become this cult
of personality with the person I mean I
had people show up at my house to
threaten my family because I said what
I'm gonna vote for the guy and I'm a
Republican on mic City Council and they
still showed up to threaten me yelled at
my kids in the grocery store it's these
people they comfortable Trump is an
extraordinary figure he can get away
with crap that nobody else can get away
with but people don't see that and I
think too many people think hey look at
how it's paid off for Trump yes this guy
a totally unqualified longshot becomes
president so he people think they can be
Trump Argentina's growing up with that
too that right I said our generation is
growing out with that to it that's
that's I think our general
[Laughter]
has been dog whistling for decades and
it was just you know couched a little
bit in more politeness before and the
dog whistle became audible to human ears
in the last few years because of Trump
but I think that strain has been there
for a very long time
who'd you vote for last night I didn't
you didn't you know oh no that's not
right
yeah I know it's my bow like this
politic sheet that [ __ ] is crazy
[Applause]
my god I mean I respect people for for
what they believe in and all the [ __ ]
but at the end of the day like if you if
you're not a solid individual then [ __ ]
you that's just how I feel personally
but whoever is president and who are our
leaders in the Senate in the house they
do affect people's lives they do in
right they do affect politics affects
people's lives in a very real way you
know John Kasich the Republican governor
I said to him you did what most
Republicans governors didn't do he
expanded Medicaid in his state and that
means hundreds of thousands of poor
people got to see a doctor that's real
[ __ ] right and that you know that's the
what happens in the voting booth
downstream that's so like what I know
about like because I mean like I
understand that but I'm like I'm in the
communities and [ __ ] oh so like when I
go to these like just me being from
Oakland but then I'll go to Miami or
hood in Miami or hood and Sagna or
something like that like a lot of those
people don't even though those those
services are out there for whatever
reason it don't reach all of the people
and then therefore they're still
struggling from that and I mean at the
end of the day like but that's where you
need a good community you had Ron
Dellums was a great man was mayor of
Oakland congresswoman barbara Lee who is
an outstanding moral leader
you should be voting for these people
because that's standing up right now
look I get out there and I just get down
with the people okay I mean I mean you
do but then I mean at the end today like
dealing with like going and dealing with
poverty
right now I get into a situation where I
want to do something in my community to
benefit more of the youth and if it
don't come with a paycheck for some of
them they're not interested in what I
say so you said that so therefore what I
so therefore what I do is I just hit the
hood of renting myself I'll pack up a
[ __ ] u-haul with either turkeys toys
for the kids and I'm and I'm out there
just giving them by myself but that's
not a long-term solution it's not a
large option can't do that you can't
bite Turtles you want to encourage the
good one summer bed but you've had again
in Oakland some very good outstanding
people who a very community booted don't
you want to encourage ants and some of
them are some of them are good yep some
of them are bad but the same conditions
in which Oakland was in back then they
still in the same situation now so then
I like it better and if they were more
of them they could succeed that's it so
we're there yet Dan I mean look at
California when when this state they
said about five years ago before Jerry
Brown became governor they said it was
on governor boat number they said it was
just it was it was a failed state and
then we elected a Democratic governor
with the Democratic legislature and our
state did a lot better and people did a
lot better and we have a surplus and it
rains now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's time to party with the people thank
you everybody
you